I'm like how do I get to be  this lucky  and  and for my brother to have like  be born with Cerebral Palsy then have a  heart transplant then have this random  blood clot like these things that are  just like you're like who has to go  through that and like how do I how do I  get to be this lucky  and there was a moment  in all of this where uh I've moved to  New York  and was like starting to get some  traction with my career  and Mike came out to visit and stay and  he looked at me and he said  every time you feel sorry for me you  make me less  and he said this is the only life I've  ever known  so stop feeling sorry for the only thing  I have  and that then created an entire  shift back  to where I think we are today which is  no just straight up equals again like  that's it why did you drift apart  jealousy  for sure at least on my part